today we are making cotton candy with
this machine I've been looking at it and
I'm really excited because it looks like
you can do all kinds of things we've got
one concern though is the candy inside
because right here it's showing the
candy that goes in I don't have any of
this candy so we're just gonna hope for
the best and hope that the candies in
here do you think the candies in here I
kind of want to say no I think the
candies in here says works with hard
candy sugar-free hard candy flock sing
sugar look bag is flossing sugar they've
got have it in here if not we'd pour
some things in and see what happens
all right it was hard candy I don't know
official unboxing you reminds me of the
fair take a look at this I'll start
opening this stuff up we've got a little
spoon what am i doing just take a look
so we can get prepped do not touch the
hot surfaces clients is not a toy
there's not gonna be handy there's no
candy in here can't be in there it's
just ludicrous thing there's candy in
here you're not gonna be in here shoot
is a very official stick I think this is
it
well you didn't show me that well I
thought this was just extra stuff this
is what we need Justine was this a bonus
pack for did you divide separately this
separately a very official machine we
should have a party oh wait Oh what the
heck never pour sugar directly into the
heating element sugar is flammable and
may result in smoke and fire this is
exactly what we need okay
oh no no no no no no there we go I
didn't want to like brisket okay cool is
that in though Oh with us to be a little
bit up like plastic is okay sure why not
that way okay me up it in look at in
tongue in robot heat it up Alexa set a
timer for 10 minutes it's gonna begin to
spin
it's spinning it's good allow you to do
that isn't this gonna make a mess no
it's gonna it's gonna melt oh wow
Dean show up show me Wow Wow little
papers in there and what don't you can
see while you move the cone the
side-to-side above the bull making sure
to collect all the cotton candy see the
image below that image is like dude look
at that show them yeah that's like
ice-truck sort of let this heat up and
then we'll start the can be expressed do
you think we can do like cotton candy
tricks like look over our spinnin you
seen this we should probably start with
one basic no you're gonna pop it in each
my cell heater it's been 10 minutes what
flavor are we gonna do it under cherry
grape great blue red great oh I like
great this is Jenna yeah we have to turn
it off okay smells like oh nice what do
you think it no I'm not gonna even tried
to taste it okay it's completely stopped
then we support in here right yeah oh
gosh is that right no one wait I'm
scared oh I love I used to love using
the scent returnees in school did you
reuse the centrifuge no oh I miss like
basics and you like take out your little
sample and you're like cool
do I stick it in there now I don't see
anything happening I don't know it
sounds good
yeah great who likes a great flavor
let's let's see a show of hands I mean I
don't not like a great flavor I just
didn't really think about great being
something no what are you doing this
it's not ready yet just wanted to make
sure it right until the web starts to
form hey there's a movie where they were
like don't I know nothing about it I
just remember being really fine they're
like Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff you guys
know let's just you know and she will
relay the message Jeff do you see a web
for me no patience my princess but how
long does it take I don't know I kind of
like skimmed over the instructions wait
is that where it goes I'm not sure oh my
god
wait god you're horrible bit have any
horizontally horrible I got it's
happening wait how did I miss the web
yeah I don't know you're like I was chat
what are you doing I don't know I'm not
I'm unsure oh my god the web the web is
happening I go to I got to get it out
though I'm concerned about the oh my
gosh things are look at this should I
start my own web okay well now I'm
screwing up everything oh you actually
start over okay there we go
we got a nice base base that looks like
a q-tip okay well you're not gonna open
up any cotton candy shop no one time
okay let me be I can't even make fun of
you guys I haven't gone you know kinda
should've watched a freaking youtube
video first my stuff is happening now
gonna keep on spinning my time oh it's
going so fast I bet you cotton candy and
or they'd Alexa who had been in cotton
candy sorry I'm not sure about that
this smells like the fair I can't like
freaking do it fast enough though what
oh what oh okay this is great this is
really actually pretty pretty cool okay
my turn my turn
take a break okay okay okay get in there
get in a hurry up
well this is gonna be an interesting get
here and now
start moving like I've got it's hot okay
go go go go belts businesses VIN look at
this that's looking good thank you
little uneven it's on lines empty
you sure oh this is all so warm so crazy
because this is like freaking plastic
horizontal minutes a horizontal hold so
we were like dipping and diving and
hatchet oh oh yeah oh yeah Poorman baby
you guys see like I can see what all
happening
yeah there you go shoots it yes oh my
god I've been in so freakin fast this
isn't a lock don't ever do that don't do
that don't do that do not drop your
sweet treat I'm Arnie Rennick do some no
I'm just gonna keep going to be the love
it's gonna give gone with it because my
heart just jumped out of my chest and
now I'm it's probably I think it's good
enough oh yeah oh man oh God Jesus I'm
gonna walk it's spider web spider web
you ready to try it yes we try the grape
you ready oh you're already going all
right Oh fruit it tastes just like grape
cotton candy it's um it's a nice taste
though I will say that I'm so hungry ask
yourself where did mine go did you eat
the whole thing
Oh God the bus will leave this one here
Wow
thank thank a piece of that oh no some
confuse how did that happen where it go
gone this is so good why I want to try
it with the hard candy the mints all
right well I have the key this is cool
there's a rifle I did not mean at all to
eat all of this I really wanted to taste
of anybody what do you think Google no
I'm not
I do nothing of the sort I'm sure Dickie
no no it's delightful this is so great
Becky what the friends come over like
they just need shows something cool and
you'll be like what I got
there you be like Oh an honorable gas
will come out and then we make not candy
well guys let me know what you think of
this because this is probably definitely
by far I think the most fun that I've
had making any sort of in a very long
time what did you think I don't mean I'm
into it I want to do it daily well thank
you guys for watching make sure you
check out Jenna's channel I'll put a
link in the description where you guys
can check this out this is not sponsored
I thought this myself good find another
one I think we're okay with one probably
this is al this is how the buildings
admin yeah I'll see you guys later
[Music]